all right
hello hi
welcome to the stream if you're watching
this sometime in the future or in the
past depending on when it is uh welcome
you are not reading the title wrong that
is the absolute truth
Ethan Ethan we all know and love or did
anyway
he's dead to me
I'll explain the details soon this is a
live stream after all so I have to wait
for everyone to get here hello hi
welcome everybody
yeah no I I know I know it's okay guys
it's okay what did Ethan do man
I wouldn't even know where to begin with
that question
this is very serious don't laugh
man I'm just you know
no he it's not click bait he betrayed me
he betrayed us all really
um because you know he betrayed me and
and in turn betrayed you guys
which um you know that's just really
I don't know you know maybe this is the
culmination of of many small things that
I've I've ignored you know because of
friendship but yeah
yeah it's tough and I hate to make like
public call outs like this but there's
no other way for me to handle it other
than just like dragging it all into the
light
the Betrayal hurts yeah it really it
really does yeah it does
all you gotta say is I'm sorry man yeah
I mean I appreciate it you're if only it
was him apologizing or not
not some random person on the internet
you know if you think about it really
that's that's all Ethan was
you know the beginning of all this just
some random guy
back flipping his way
into my life
and then he just had to
front flip out
what happened uh where do I even begin
it was a lovely day I thought anyway
lovely day who's Ethan again
man
who is Ethan you know I asked myself the
same question
and and at this point in my my life and
my existence I I keep asking myself that
because you think you know someone and
then you know the true colors get
revealed and
the true
the true colors get revealed and you
just
I don't know
do you really know anyone can you really
know anyone if you don't even really
know yourself how can you really know
someone else
yeah
I don't know
I'm gonna make you cry
I've cried enough tears for all of us
already
man I've cried so much sometimes I can't
tell if I'm crying or I'm laughing but
there's no joy definitely not
Ethan must be punished I don't know if
revenge is the right answer but it'll
definitely feel good
you know getting all this out and just
like emptying my soul onto the internet
is the purest form of
therapy
in reality if we all think about it
ain't got no tears left that's true
that's very true what did he do I'm I'm
getting to it I'm getting to it I'm
getting to it this is me telling about
it right now but to get through all of
it you got to go to the beginning you
got to go to the very beginning
gotta go to the beginning of all of it
can you tell a story halfway you got to
tell a story hallway you can't half-ass
a story you got a whole ass
and you know Ethan's just been
half-assing life if you think about it
did he not give you Taco Bell as bad as
that sounds uh no he's much much worse
I'm not stalling I gotta go back to the
beginning
can you can Rush the lore I don't think
you can I don't think you can Rush this
because the lore of life
takes its own time you know this
betrayal was cooking up for a very very
very long time yeah
not stalling I'll tell you what it was
it was a lovely day or so I thought like
I said before
and you know
Ethan and I
we're catching up you know catching up
like we do you know frolicking in the
park
tossing the old pigskin you know
anyway we were conversing we were
conversating we were we were talking we
were discussing things we were saying
things to each other we're exchanging
words you know
and I mentioned how
how much I loved Garden of band pan
I was mentioning just
my deep deep love for garden of banban
and he was like yes yes it's true Garden
of bam ban is truly one of the greatest
games it's truly one of the games of all
time is what he said to me he said that
this is actually true there's 100 true
I'm not joking about any of this this is
actually true
and I said to him
um that's telling him you know like I
didn't understand all the hate regarding
them
and he was like yeah yeah man yeah man
what a what a great what what a game
what a that game is there this is a dead
true I'm not lying
that's what we were talking about more
and I was like yeah
yeah man can't wait can't wait
for ban ban six and or five
but you know the Betrayal is or it was
or the Betrayal train had already left
the station at this point
because
what bet did I lose I didn't lose a bet
I lost the bet that I I bet my dignity
on that friendship and I lost you know I
lost that bit I lost it
I I lost that bet
I'm like one of the characters from um
LA Noire just can you tell them am I
lying are you gonna
[Music]
I'm so sad you know anyway so we look in
the back uh log of what else the
developers of garden the band Bannon
made and we found this game called well
I found I want to be very clear I found
this game called Egghead gumpty right
okay right that's very important
remember that Egghead gumpty that bad
name that name is very important right
so
so I tell them I tell them this because
you know Ethan Ethan you know do you do
you know that Ethan is no longer crank
gameplays crank gameplays is dead or so
we all thought
and I tell them in confidence that I'm
like I know the next big thing I know I
know it's I I know it's gonna carry
gaming into the next Century I know what
the what I know what's gonna
I know it's gonna
um carry us into forever
is Egghead gumpty I told them this I
told him this in confidence and I was
like I'm gonna make a video on Egghead
gumpty and I can't wait for it because
because it's going to be the next big
thing it's gonna be the next chapter of
me making content on YouTube I know this
to be true and I told them this I told
them this
and I thought you know I've been busy
you know I've been you know editing the
movie and doing all kinds of other stuff
and I I'm like yeah I told him this like
yeah I'm gonna do this I I told them all
about Egghead gumpty all my dreams and
Ambitions for it
and then
what do you know
we all thought that crank gameplays was
dead and buried gone forever and it was
just Ethan Nester and then a week ago
a week ago
here comes along a little uh
notification in my sub box
of which I will no longer be getting
notifications because I unsubscribed
well okay you can't really tell which
one it is here well I mean you can
because he said he said that he would
stop doing gaming content
and yet what do you know ten days ago
10 days ago
he he not only because I told him this I
told him this just about 11 days ago
right I told him about the next chapter
in gaming Evolution 11 days ago and what
did he do what did he do he ran off
and immediately when I gotta record this
I gotta get ahead of the gumpty train
and then call boom what do you see oh
this is the new standard for horror
games that is literally the quote that I
said to him I said to him this was going
to be the new standard for horror games
and he doesn't even just take the game
suggestion out of my mouth he doesn't
even take my great ideas out of my brain
he steals the words from my throat
he stole everything right from under me
he just whoops all gone so you all
thought that this wasn't a real betrayal
can you believe that the honor that we
as YouTubers hold to each other is
sacred and he threw it on the ground and
stomped all over it because oh he had to
just get a sweet sweet taste of Egghead
gumpty long before hope I'm doing well
thanks for the hundo I'm not I'm not
doing well
foreign
[Music]
I'm not doing well at all can you see
can you see this can you see this you
seeing this I you know that was even
going to be like the thumbnail I was
gonna make I can't I can't fathom
I can't fathom the audacity I can't
fathom the pure
how could he how could he I don't even
know I don't even know Benedict Nester
I don't even know how how Ethan Nestor
could have possibly done this could have
possibly done
I don't know how how he could have done
this
I guess you never really know what um
what people are capable of the evil that
is cooking up inside you you know this
this mind here the kind of Horrid truths
that are lurking deep beneath this
surface you know you'd think you'd know
but you really don't
do ya do you do ya do you no you know
anyway
let's do a let's do a video review I
built the dog house and it went terribly
three hours ago I bet it did I bet it
you know what I bet it did
I bet it did if our Creations are a
mirror of our own Souls I bet that
turned out very poorly huh I bet it did
Ethan
or should I say crank gameplays what is
it now what even is it anymore
I don't even know
whatever and we don't even need to talk
about this anymore just
both makes me angry and terribly sad
terribly sad
pathetic thumbnail terrible honestly I
have to do this oh yeah yeah sure yep
just uh putting another crying thumbnail
Here trailer for his documentary more
like
bad that's what I have to say about that
not subscribed yeah not subscribed you
know what you know immediately
immediately immediately immediately no
longer subscribed no longer subscribed
no longer
so what is this reacting let me see that
yeah real oh real tasteful real tasteful
there I can't believe it just
fully sold out you know that's that's
what Ethan's done just fully 100 sold
out how dare he make an only fans who
would even dare do that I can't believe
this I can't believe this was this a
backstabbing of you Evan uh-huh how well
do I know jacksepticeye well how well do
we know Ethan Nestor apparently zero
apparently nothing yeah apparently
absolutely nothing disgusting that's
true absolutely the Betrayal the outrage
yeah I can't believe this can't believe
it's not even making his own content
anymore just remixing
oh yeah oh wow yeah good good stuff good
great great great great
can you believe it
I cannot I
I can't believe it
okay
um so are you two not friends yeah I
would say absolutely friendship ended um
uh and you know this kind of betrayal is
something that really opens your eyes to
uh the truth of what a person really is
and I uh you know I'm just glad that I
finally uh came to my senses
and then uh we'll
it's just it's just a video
I'm sorry it's just a video
it's just
it's just the video
it's just honestly this is this is a
life
this is life so if you think it's just a
video then maybe you need to reevaluate
your priorities
yeah first it's a video and then who
knows
who knows where it would go who knows
this is terrible I hope you get through
this one thank you that's really that's
that's the response I was um
I was I was looking thank you now you
truly understand what I'm going through
I truly understand yes thank
who said that I don't know you know it
was probably Ethan on his alt account
just just
um YouTube would never Ethan already did
Ethan already done this was 10 days ago
ten days ago I've sat on this and I've
stood on it and I've let it Fester
inside my soul and no more
no more I shan't have it I should
I shan't have it
if you missed what he did I'm not going
to get back into it again you're gonna
have to wait until the stream ends and
you can watch the archive or if there's
a DVR on this thing maybe go for there
what's going on here what did it even do
this time
I just I can't speak on it anymore I
gotta let the past be the past if you
missed it you missed it
it's uh this is one way to help your
friend's Channel by trying to build heat
and quote drama to help generate more
views for him
what
Dash ridiculous
that's absurd shut up stupid man that's
probably Ethan on his alt account just
being the terrible human being
anyway
um so yeah anyway whatever I needed an
excuse I I had an idea for a thumbnail
and I I went with that but it's true I
actually did this is not actually a lie
I told him about Egghead gumpty I told
him about it that's all true and then he
went out there and played it before me
everything I said is true nothing that I
said in this stream was a lie not a one
thing all of that happened all of that
occurred and it's up to you to decide
how horrible it was
how horrible
how horrible he betrayed me you know
what I mean
help hope you're doing all right I don't
know
[Music]
Ethan losing 100 of his followers and
it's deserved Unforgivable
anyway uh it's high high by the way
um this is just gonna be a chat and
stream like uh I just wanted to catch up
I um bath been incredibly busy I'm
really shifting gears you're probably
getting Whiplash from how hard I'm
shifting gears here
um but I've been incredibly busy like
extraordinarily busy but all for good
reasons for those of you who don't know
um I've been in the uh post-production
process for iron lung and that's been
going incredibly well
um
very happy about like uh the progress
and there's some exciting things on the
horizon for that but I wanted to catch
up because there's another reason why I
haven't been uploading videos uh it's
actually like a personal reason that I
haven't been in addition to being very
busy
um and it's a it's not like anything
calamitous it's something that I've
actually mentioned before
um in either distractible or other
things uh but it's like it's been very
difficult for me to focus on work or
multiple things that I have to do
because I'm always doing a bunch of
different things because I haven't been
able to get my ADHD medication
um so I didn't want to have like a long
break on my channel I never like to do
that
um but if I have to you know I do when I
was filming earlier this year obviously
I was on set for like 14 hours a day on
average
um and then I would come home and there
would be no time to even think about
recording something and then the
weekends were very busy so things like
that is like understandable if I'm not
able to post videos but the the
unfortunate thing was
um yeah I know again again yes uh it's
well it's not even the shortest thing so
if you don't if you guys don't know
there has been a shortage in like ADHD
medications
um and that has been affecting people uh
but mine was like compounded because not
only I talked about it in like uh ruin
that's that's when I was talking about
it is like that's when the problem
started and I thought it would be like
fixed before that
um but I said in ruin my doctor just
kind of stopped answering the phone
and that was that was very strange my
doctor just stopped answering the phone
which
apparently that can just happen
um so I I I've been without medication
for a while and I and I talk on and off
about ADHD and some things like that
usually in member streams I talk about
it more
um but it's actually been affecting my
ability to keep up with my channel in
general
um and it's uh it's something that I
just wanted to talk about not I'm not
trying to be like apologized or an
explanation this is my life and I deal
with it as I can but I I think it's
helpful for you guys to understand a
little bit of it because once again
there was this clip that I I talked
about in distractible about ADHD that's
going making the rounds again on Tick
Tock and other social media about me
talking about my experience with ADHD
and one thing I want to clarify is those
what I said in that clip was how I felt
a long time ago
um when I was about 16 years old when it
was at its worst before I got diagnosis
before any of that stuff before I even
realized I had it before I did any of
the work to build up from there
um and the reason I want to clarify is
not because that I I'm trying to
backtrack anything that I said there I'm
trying to add additional context to it
and how it applies and kind of give a
retrospective of where I am today in my
life
um and so I got diagnosed about when I
was like 20 something like that I I went
to a doctor myself and I found one and I
was just like I gotta I gotta get an
answer about this I gotta get an answer
and so I went
and then I got tested and they were like
yep you have it and here start this
medication routine and yada yada
um and it was life-changing it wasn't
life-changing just because of the
medication that helped a lot but it was
life-changing just to know like
that I had it you know because then when
you know you can start from a place of
certainty instead of constantly
wondering uh where you're coming from
um but what I want to say is like versus
where I am today I'm still able even
without medication I'm still able to
keep up with some of the work that I
have to do like I was editing videos
every day even though I wasn't able to
get my prescription
and this is something that I want people
to recognize for those of you out there
with ADHD or something similar you know
um it's not that you shouldn't be
without your medication it's just I
don't want anyone to ever think that
it's completely hopeless if you don't
have it because the the medication is
one thing but the therapy is like an
entire another part of it having habits
and building habits and building strong
habits uh in the interim uh is what can
carry you through so that you can feel
like you can stay on top of things it
may not get you all the way there and
I'm kind of like telling you a living
example of this in the past two months
that I wasn't able to get everything
that I wanted to do done and I had to
I had to take more breaks than I ever
would have normally done and I'd have to
like try like take less time in doing
things so that my own brain could feel
like it wasn't going insane
um it's tough it is tough and that's why
also I think that it's it's important
for people to realize that just like
having a a medicine or something like
that isn't always going to be the
complete fix but it's part of it and
there's a stigma around medications too
and I'm trying to like both
both clarify that the daily practice and
routines that you set yourself are
important and also the medication if it
helps you don't need to feel bad about
taking it either yeah and uh
what about
what about snot dripping down my nose
am I am I crying is there snot
everywhere am I blasting snot out of
every orifice no
uh there
sounds like a horrible horror game
uh ADHD yeah something like that yeah
sometimes it can be nope you're good
thank you thank you very much I don't
know why that one comment in the the
like blur of comments sometimes gets
like jumps out to me and this is part of
the ADHD
um but what I was saying before I got
horribly sidetracked by that uh is that
when it comes down to uh like where I am
now
um I was able to do the work on the
movie but I wasn't able to record videos
and I definitely wasn't able to keep up
with that because it's really hard to
shift gears
um when you're trying to get many things
done when you have ADHD it's really
really hard uh and thankfully thankfully
finally I was able to find a new doctor
because that was the biggest challenge
is like just find something that was
going to take a new patient and I was
able to get a prescription for a stars
and I was able to actually get that
filled and I was actually like just as
of last week get back on it and it's
been it's been much better and as you
can tell on the channel I've started
posting videos again which is great
because I've also been doing work on the
movie and I've I've actually been able
to multitask and it hasn't been feeling
too overwhelming and I've been able to
actually keep on top of things and
that's that's exactly what I'm talking
about
um because it is it is compounding and
and like there's a lot of different
facets to it and there's a lot of
different uh reasons to go with one
therapy versus another but like the
currently where I'm at and thankfully
thankfully a stars does not have the
shortage because for those of you out
there there's there's a bunch of
different types of medication
um but there has been like this this
Nationwide shortage for about a year now
like a year or so
um and it doesn't seem like it's going
to get any better
um but like at least the medication that
I'm currently on is in stock and I'm
able to get that and it seems to be
working for me a lot better uh than my
last one
um so all in all it's very good and uh
I'm able to keep up with videos and I'm
able to keep up with stuff so even
though even though Ethan got ahead of
the video before I got to the glory that
his Egghead gumpty you know that's
that's my reasoning for it that's my
excuse for it
yeah
why is there a shortage I don't know
I've I have no idea the last I heard and
this is like the dumb pharmaceutical
Industries like there's there's like
limits on how much of that stuff that
companies can make or something like
that
um and for some reason one reason or
another the pharmaceutical companies
that make it
we're not fulfilling the maximum of
their allotted amount and I don't know
why I'm I again I have no idea that's
that's far beyond me all I get to do is
be pissed at you know the various issues
that I run into yeah why am I mad at
Ethan he he he I told him I was going to
play a game and he he snuck it out
before me I snuck it out before me grow
up more
about what about Ethan never I'm never
gonna forgive him about that I'm never
gonna forgive him he's dead to me
forever and a day absolutely
um am I excited about the FNAF movie
um I can't speak to anything wink about
the FNAF movie wink wonk I couldn't
possibly say a single word about the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie wink wink
wink yeah
um sounds like a skill issue which one
ADHD
yeah what an insult
that sounds like a skillet
this is confusing no way it's not
confusing I am so excited wink wink wink
wank for the movie
stop being such a tease I'm not teasing
I just love winking
I love it
I think it's more funny that you're not
tricking anyone anymore about what
what's the true answer
say it definitively
about anything
am I tricking you I'm not tricking
anybody because it's not a trick wink
wonk
wink a wonk cancels out the wink I don't
know if you knew that
uh am I going to twitchcon uh no I don't
have time for anything I don't have time
for anything this is the reason why you
have trust issues that's it's not really
my fault though if you have trust issues
I've been very consistent in my
untrustworthiness for quite some time
now
taken my d my deep voice please
this is deep enough for you I don't know
what you mean by deep voice
is this
D for you
I can't I don't think I can go any
deeper maybe a little bit more
um how's my only fans oh god I didn't
even say that the only Fan's money has
been donated I forgot to tell you guys
about that
um so yeah the the money uh was
withdrawn and split up I ended up uh not
doing a third drop even though I said I
would
um mostly just because I wasn't able to
take the time to actually edit the
videos that's how busy it was and it was
getting so late after the process
because I did I started the only fans
and then I went off and filmed a movie
uh and then I had to do all the
post-production stuff for the movie so I
literally didn't have any time and it
got to about like June and I was like
Frick it's been like half a year and I
haven't even gotten this gotten this
money over uh so I ended up just like I
I withdrew the money and I sent it off
to the uh charitable organization so
that is already there I can post proof
of that if you guys would like uh but it
has been donated and all of that money
is to the right
places and people yeah
when am I gonna
I played Cod on camera I just did it I
just did it I literally just did caught
on camera I did that
it did yeah
the tastefulness yes very very tasteful
did I
pledge it or donated donated did I say
pledge no it's it's wait what would even
be the difference I have no idea it's
donated the money is in their hands
yes
yes that's the correct answer anyway
I'll get proof soon like just because I
always like to be transparent about that
stuff
hey Mark I have a question uh I mean you
can ask it but I just so happen to see
this comment of you saying that you have
a question I cannot guarantee I'm going
to see the follow-up because if you've
seen chat it's a little bit fast yeah
um
favorite superhero
I don't really have one no I don't have
one slender the Arrival replay oh yeah I
forgot that they're actually gonna make
another one of those
I did forget about it put on slow mode
oh this is slow mode uh this is yeah it
doesn't get much slower than this yeah
first time ever seeing me live oh yeah
thank you yeah I just wanted to catch up
because it has been a little bit talked
about like why I haven't been uploading
videos and what I've been working on and
also the fact that I need to um
I need to keep working basically is what
I'm going to say I've actually recorded
some extra videos so I have more videos
lined up for a little bit here
um but there's a very exciting
opportunity for me uh that I have to
apply myself 100 for and I you know I
love making I love doing this stuff
I love making content and I've really
enjoyed working on this movie it's such
a fun challenge
um and basically for the next two weeks
I'm going to be doing nothing but that
uh barring the exception of trying to
make a video here and there and getting
videos posted and I do want to do that I
absolutely do yeah there's uh but
there's something really cool on the
horizon that I'm going to be kind of
putting all my effort into you know uh
quote me last time saying putting my
whole marcusi into this I'm going to be
doing that except with a lot more regret
of saying that out loud than I had last
time and I had a lot of regrets saying
that out loud yeah
you just started YouTube because of me
oh well good luck uh I hope you enjoy it
yeah something cool it is yeah I I do
want to I wanna be a little less
secretive about you know this project as
I have been in the past I love doing the
whole ARG thing and the teasing it and
the being obscure about it but at the
same time like this is just really fun
project it's a really fun thing that's
happening uh but for right now I have to
be a little bit
I still have to keep a little bit secret
but very soon there's going to be some
cool stuff happening I
I'm just having a great time I when is
the trailer for iron alone coming out I
have the next trailer literally ready to
go
um I did get approval from sag to be
able to promote it so we are approved
um but at the same time I'm holding off
just because there is something really
cool on the horizon and I kind of want
to tie it up a little bit Yeah I want
everything to to fall at the same time
Reveal Your Secrets so you're gonna get
the secrets soon you're gonna hear about
everything very very soon so don't worry
about anything it's all gonna come out
very soon but for now again I gotta like
notice that the grindstone work on this
and and just not stop working on it
until it's done yeah
Mark just happy to be here at player I
am you know what I am I actually am I
feel a lot better now that I actually
have medication and I'm able to get my
prescription like that does help a lot
um but it it also I want to be very
clear that I've been excited to work on
this
um because it's kind of an application
of all of my skills when I say I put you
know my whole self into this it really
is a culmination of
you know everything I've worked on for a
very long time and it's exciting because
I'm just at like the beginning of it and
I'd say that uh in space with markiplier
was probably the culmination of 10 years
of me learning stuff on YouTube and then
putting that all into one project
everything that I've learned distilled
down to one thing right if that's what I
had to describe space was that's what it
is in all the terms that it is and also
in the overly ambitious terms that it is
and I think I did really well I think it
was it was great
um but you know Iron long is kind of
like it's kind of the first foray into a
wider world of of Bigger Productions and
even though I can say like I've I've
done this stuff kind of before it's
exciting to me that there is a whole
world left to learn about Productions
and about video making and about
essentially content creation even though
you can hardly call a movie content
um but you know making things making
things has always been my passion making
things you know on the Internet is is
such a fulfilling thing and and to me
this is just a bigger version of that
you know that's just like it's another
exciting chapter of it and there's a lot
to it
that leaves me with the only conclusion
that like my God I got to keep up with
him oh my God I gotta learn so much
there's so much cool stuff out there you
know it's great
I just love it I love every part of it
yeah
um I mean we're gonna get iron lung
merch why is that the main priority here
why is that the main priority you're
gonna get a movie
am I gonna make another movie after
Ireland oh yeah I mean I'm gonna make
another whatever if you ask me am I
gonna make another anything the answer
is probably yes um I've always said it
that I'm going to be sliding into the
grave wishing I could make one more
thing
um but you know yeah I'm gonna keep
making stuff as long as I have more to
learn I'm going to keep making stuff
yeah
um yes iron lung will be in theaters uh
I again I don't know about International
though but it's going to be in theaters
that's what it's intended for
um just don't know when yet and I will
let you know exactly uh when possible
another hate video yes this is another
hate video I hate Ethan Nester
friendship ended
how did the strike influence filming uh
it didn't really we were already done
filming by the time the strikes happened
it affected it a little bit in terms of
post-production because you know you
need ADR and stuff like that but uh
really we were we were all done filming
anyway so it's all good I've just been
knee-deep in the editing process yeah
blood merch win yeah
um I was chica chica's great cheek is
good chica is really good if you saw
Chico recently took over the channel in
uh scary games 101 so if you haven't
seen that it's gonna she's doing good
she's very good
mark on his deathbed one more movie dies
yeah pretty much
I've got no updates on edge of sleep
like I've always said that's out of my
hands that's not my purview of things so
I can't tell you anything because I
don't know anything yeah
did I break the blood record I'm almost
positive that we did I'm almost positive
that we did and it's hard to say okay so
what what that means is for this movie I
think we have the world record for most
amount of uh blood used in a movie and
I'm almost 100 sure that we have that
um and I'm I say that with confidence
because I there are other claims uh from
other movies for amounts of blood uh we
have a verifiable number of amount of
blood that we used uh from multiple
different metrics and I and I I've said
this before I think but I'm going to say
it again
if you take red dye and you put it in
water that's not fake blood that's red
water there's a big difference between
actually getting some special effects
fake blood and some red water so let's
uh let's be very honest with ourselves
so if anyone's claiming to make a a kind
of world record attempt
you got to have actual fake blood first
that's funny to say actual fake blood
but I think everyone everyone in the
movie industry probably knows what I'm
talking about or anyone else anywhere
yeah yeah guys it was real blood I win
you know that had been considered I'm
probably saying a little too much there
but that had been considered because I
was looking up um and there was an
episode of Fear Factor right way back in
the day there was an episode of Fear
Factor that uh had contestants basically
like bobbing for organs in a pool of
fake blood or real blood quote unquote
real blood again the claim is one thing
but can you verify it is another and so
that Fear Factor episode has you know
there's images of it and it looks horrid
it looks it looks like they're swimming
in Blood and for all I know it is
because they say it's like they got it
from slaughterhouses right they got
excess blood from slaughterhouses and
they just filled a pool with it horrible
right unethical in many many degrees uh
but
that was a thing that was a thing so
it's like when I say consider it I
didn't say like oh I really want to pour
real blood in here but it was just one
of those things where it's like how what
other Productions have ever had like an
Ocean's amount of blood right and you
look up that and you you look up the
picture and it's like holy oh my
God so it's not actually gonna be well
it's not actually ever going to be
considered but it's like apparently that
can happen
apparently you sign enough waivers and
you can make anything occur
yeah
uh
wait I miss use Ethan's blood
is the blood processed when you buy real
blood I don't know
I don't know I've never bought real
blood before I don't know I don't know
what the processing you would do is I I
don't know do you pasteurize it I don't
know I don't know anyway yeah
NDA your way to blood
yeah as long as you guys don't ask
questions of where the blood came from I
think we're all gonna
have a great movie I can't wait to cut
my hair can't wait to come here
can't wait to come here Jesus did you
have to use an anticoagulant we did not
use real blood
that's what I don't need everybody
walking out of this to say we did not
use real blood this is not real blood
nothing anything can happen when you
sign enough waivers I want to make all
of you sign waivers I I'm not gonna
don't cut the hair please you don't
understand you don't understand
I'm so sick of it I'm so sick of it I'm
so sick of eating my own hair I'm so
sick of it getting in my eyes I'm so
sick of it it's my that's why I've been
wearing the headband most of the time is
it because like I can't deal with it
just constantly going in my mouth
anyway
not real blood not real blood no
no
um I have some ideas for videos that are
going to be coming out soon I had one
that I didn't know if it was going to
work or not and I think it I think it
does I'll check if it's done actually
that might be tomorrow but
yeah I uh
I got some good ideas of things coming
up I've got more review videos too that
I think will be fun if you if you
recognize my face from the thumbnail
it's from the uh it's from the uh Takis
is dead to me video so that's where that
came from so I want to do more views too
but for the next two weeks I really got
a buckle down and I got to work on some
stuff
um it's gonna be worth it I think you'll
see you'll you'll realize sooner than
you know why I was uh working so hard on
this and why I was sprinting so much on
this
um but like you'll see it's also it is a
lot easier with my prescription
um like not only that is just like
I've been if you listen to distract
people I've been struggling to switch my
medication for almost a year now and uh
I finally have been able to get a
consistent Supply and it's it's very
nice it is it is much better than what I
was on before I used to take adderall
and now I take as far as and it's it's
working out a lot better for me I can
actually sleep and that's you'd be
surprised at how much that just affects
everything you know not even if you have
ADHD or not but quality sleep is one of
the most important things that you could
possibly do and so um yeah that's very
very important but one of many things
yeah so now that I'm actually able to do
that I'm going to be focusing on you
know just getting this stuff done I
always love working on this stuff and I
I do love a deadline and I love a
challenging parameter uh with which to
do something and um no no there's this
cool opportunity in front of me and I'm
going to do everything I can to I don't
know make it happen I I think like
that's really what boils down my desire
to make stuff is my entire career has
been you know there's been opportunities
which you could consider to be luck in
terms of what I do in content Creation
in general
um but there's when there's an
opportunity and you have a chance to
Excel and exceed yourself and rise to
the occasion I always love chances like
that there's so few and far between and
and this is just like a really wonderful
opportunity for it
it's really cool so yeah I'm gonna get
there yep
yeah I don't think no I don't think I'm
gonna Buzz my head I don't think I'm
gonna buzz it but I I am excited to get
rid and go back to short I think that
short will be lovely
and I think I think that I uh I think
that see this is exactly what I'm
talking about it gets in your hair it
gets in your goddamn higher it gets in
your hair
I could for the right reason I would for
the right reason I would Buzz my head
but I haven't had the right reason I
might I might do it
I might I haven't buzzed my head don't
for God please don't but it grows back
you know it does
for legal reasons I have to tell you
it's not real blood yeah it does grow
back it does at least for now it grows
back so it wouldn't be that long yeah we
don't care
I I don't understand why people are so
attached to my hair at any given time
yeah
the love of God don't my description
says it's Garden abandoned it does it
oops
oh I forgot to change that
oh sorry whatever yeah
nah it's fine
okay it's just a pain in the ass it's a
pain in the ass
red hair again no way I'm never gonna
dye my hair again
I don't think ever again
huh will iron lung have guard in the
band man I don't even know what that
means I don't even think you know what
that means I don't think you know any of
what that means
I don't think you understand what you're
even talking about
why is Ethan dead to me oh man you gotta
go back in time you got to go back in
time
to the beginning of the stream not go
back in time I gotta go back in time and
undo the decision to be his friend in
the first place but you know you got to
go back in time
hopefully you just wake up like it's
kind of like that wake up from akova
it's just someone you've got to go back
in time you have to go back in time
right now you got to go back in time
this is your message you gotta go back
in time right now yeah it's like if you
don't you know you'll never wake up from
the coma yeah how much blood is too much
blood I think I found out
I think I found out dude we use so much
blood that um
you literally have to start thinking of
the sheer weight of how much liquid
you're using like that is an active
consideration when you get to the
quantities that we are using is just
wondering if the structural Integrity of
walls are going to hold
that's that's when you get into the
quantities of you know you might you
might have too much yeah anyway
did you drink it afterwards uh I mean I
I ended up drinking a little bit of it
but it wasn't intentional no at all
yeah
what did Ethan do yeah
gonna have to ask someone else
yeah
what is blood yapping about what is
blood do you not know what blood is
did it taste good not at all not at all
no absolutely zero absolutely zero
yeah
yeah it was a lot that hence why I think
we have the record
how do we get rid of it
um
that's a good question
uh I should note the answer to that I
should know the answer to that I know we
we did it responsibly
um I'll get back to you on that one I'll
get back to you on that one yeah
um
Mark you were a massive inspiration for
me throughout my life along with other
creators I'll eventually get my first
computer ever so I could possibly start
trying to do content myself again thanks
for raising me as did for millions of
others all right well thank you very
much but I want to point out I didn't
raise anybody I didn't raise you all
would turn out much more messed up if if
that was the case no we disposed of it
we dispose it but thank you very much
well we disposed of it we did dispose of
it
responsibly ethically we did definitely
there isn't just a lake out there
somewhere
that just got mysteriously really bloody
all of a sudden
no no no no no
no no no no no not at all
not at all not at all
definitely not
yeah anyway
um
use my spear on Ethan I don't no I don't
think so sons of the force win uh
whenever Bob and Wade get off their lazy
behinds and record with me actually no I
just been very busy so I haven't been
able soon enough I will yeah
yeah
absolutely anyway any final questions
before I close it up here I got more
work to do today I gotta record at least
like a couple more videos and then
hopefully no hopefully I can get go get
going on that
um but any last minute question before I
leave not game suggestions not asking oh
are you gonna play this I don't care
about that I think I'm some kind of
gamer
not at all
you miss me I miss you guys too I miss
making videos so it's good it's gonna be
back yeah
oh going too fast I can't even read it
anymore
oh
no game suggestions no game suggestions
no no this is seeing a lot of oh God
uh
do you really not lying about Ethan not
lying he's dead to me
uh
what happened you're late too late
criminal what was the blood for the
movie
um
how was my day my day was good we just
got back actually
um it's it's actually really cool I got
back from a talking sound with the sound
engineer you guys might have heard me
talk about this guy named Brad
um so Brad works uh has worked on the
other projects that I've done space and
Heist um and he did the sound mixing for
those and he's a very talented dude he's
also fun to work with
um he also recently finally won an award
he won an Emmy um because he missed uh
uh fathom so he did fathom on Apple TV
which is a a
documentary about documentary movie
about whales and whale noises and
talking to whales I actually have to
watch it he showed me some of the work
that he'd done and I didn't even realize
um like how connected that work would be
to what we're doing now
um because it's about whale sounds and
it's about underwater stuff and it's
like that is that is oddly topical
Mark do you have any advice for dealing
with ADHD
um I do uh but a lot of what I would say
would be kind of an easier said than
done situation you know
um I would say the things that have
helped me a lot are
setting a schedule in terms of sleep
that is that is crucial in my mind
um and sticking to it I've been I've
been on the same relatively similar
sleep schedule for about
eight years now and that has gone a long
way to help out the consistency of the
day
um also the fir this applies to anybody
even if you don't have ADHD the first
thing that you do in the day will
directly impact how the rest of your day
is and how your mental state is during
the rest of the rest of the day but
especially for ADHD
um so if the first thing you do is open
your phone and look at Tick Tock you
know
that that should be an indication that
you know it's not going to set the right
pace the whole concept of like waking up
on the right side of the bed is
important
um I would not recommend keeping your
phone by your bed when you go to sleep
and I know that can sound like sacrilege
uh but trust me like you don't realize
how addicted you are addicted you are to
your phone until you take it away at
night and in the morning because if you
think of it like this imagine if you
were a smoker some of you may be
um and you wake up in the first the
first thing you do in the day is smoke a
cigarette like that that's an indication
of something that you can't go without
it right it's an addiction and I think
like people don't realize how addicted
they are to their phones I'm not saying
throw your phone away that's not what
I'm saying just like at a certain time
at night don't do it put your phone away
keep your phone away from you and then
at a certain time when you wake up don't
go for it first thing right that's
really it sounds like such a small thing
it is actually a very big psychological
hurdle but that it's one of the simplest
things you can do because it sets the
pace for your day gets your brain time
to actually wake up and and be aware
um and then just don't be afraid of your
own like of actually being in your own
head uh meditation is something that
helps a lot there's a there's a
a neuroscientist Andrew huberman I think
he is he he's done an episode on ADHD
that talks about it a lot and um I I
haven't been very consistent about this
one
um he recommends like in the morning
about 18 minutes which is a weird amount
of time uh meditation for 18 minutes
just trying to mindfully think about
what your day is that really does help I
have not been able to consistently do
that or incorporate it into it but I do
hope to do that someday I've heard that
helps a lot uh so definitely if you want
to try something that would be one of
them but a regular sleep schedule and
then not getting on your phone which I'm
not perfect about either
um is definitely going to be the main
thing that you should do
um talking to your doctor working on
like a routine and planning things out
medication does help but getting the
right medication does help
um I hate to say it but there's a lot of
like blanket sweep
um prescriptions that go out there and
like typical things and there there are
a lot of like newer medications and
newer treatments that are out nowadays
that are significantly better at least
in my experience I can't tell you which
one specifically uh but I would
recommend talking to a medical
professional about that that's again way
more than what I could do yeah
um and then other than that that's
that's about that's about it that's all
I can say for now in this short amount
of time that I have
um would you ever act in big movies If
You Ever Had the Chance uh maybe it just
depends on what it is uh and what you
define as like a big movie
um
I you know believe it or not I don't
absolutely
live to act is is a thing I've worked
very hard at it because I hate being bad
at things
um but I'm not really I'm not really
here to be like the greatest actor that
ever lived
um do you like acting or directing more
I like directing more in in all honesty
um most of what I do because I'm in
front of the cameras just because of my
channel and like they're my ideas so I
feel like I should execute them it's not
by any desire to be in the Limelight or
whatever you know it's just like I I
like crafting stories and I like making
things and usually you know if you're
starting out you got to do everything
yourself anyway so yeah that's what I do
and if I'm gonna be in front of the
camera I don't want to be bad so I I
work on that yeah what about add I I
couldn't tell you the difference I don't
even know yeah
is the movie going to be PG-13
ah
no
what part of what part of blood ocean
don't you understand
anyway yeah
is it X-rated
oh it's definitely not wink wunk wink
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think you'd be a great GM for a
tabletop RPG I would never have the time
I would never have the time but maybe I
think that would be pretty fun that
would be pretty nice
yeah
will the movie be for babies I
I don't think so I don't know maybe I
don't know it depends on the baby I
guess yeah why do I gotta join it
x-rated listen you gotta join sometime
why is Ethan dead to me I've already
explained this
I'm I don't even want to hear his name
ever again
um
wait
is it really a movie and how long can
it gets really a movie of movie length
of course it's a movie yeah it's got to
be in theaters am I anxious for the
movie no not really I've never really
been anxious about any of my projects
that I made mostly just because I I get
anxious about
um
what do I get anxious about
I get anxious about uh
I was anxious this past month just
because it was hard for me to focus uh
so I was like where you're like oh man I
I really got to get this done and like
getting behind never feels good so that
gives me anxiety but once once it's done
I always know that a project is as good
as it can be because that's as good as I
could do and I put everything I have
into it and that's as good as it will be
that's what's carried me through YouTube
for a very long time movies would be no
different
um but at the same time must be nice to
not get anxious over everything I I
don't have time to get anxious really I
mean I'm not saying I'm immune to it I
do get anxious like I just said getting
behind gets me anxious like I just I
don't like missing deadlines and I don't
like missing out on time and also like
because I'm so focused on the work the
work itself doesn't get me anxious what
are all the other things that I miss out
on because I'm so focused on the work
that does get me anxious I'm just so
hyper focused on it that I don't even
have time to worry about it and and also
I recognize it you know it no matter
what it's not going to be perfect
nothing that you make ever is going to
be perfect it's just gonna be the best
that you can do and so long as you do
the best you can do like what anyone
else says has no no effect on how I move
forward with what I do I'm still gonna
make another thing afterwards I'm still
gonna put everything I have into it and
I'm still gonna do it as good as I can
and that's what's allowed me to be where
I am today where I have the skills to do
these things if you spend so long
worrying about like whether people are
gonna like it you lose out on the idea
of you liking it in the first place and
so me when I look at this stuff I just
work on it until I like it and once I
like it that doesn't change based on
what anyone else says I still like it
because I was in the trenches making me
like it working it to the point where I
liked it I was going through the entire
process of getting the point where I
like it me liking it is a long journey
that no one else walked and I'm not
gonna walk them down that journey I
don't have time to walk them down to the
place if they like it and so me wasting
time trying to convince someone else
that they should like my thing is not my
problem that's their problem if they
don't like it that's not my problem and
it's also not something I'm gonna hold
against them because they didn't go
through all the process to like it and
maybe it's just not their type of thing
I didn't make it for them I made it for
me I made it because I like making
things and once I like the thing that I
make I make another thing that I like
and that's that's pretty much My
Philosophy it's not groundbreaking it's
not like revolutionary in terms of
thought processes but that's just what I
do that that's what I've always done
that's anything I've ever done on
YouTube is or any other type of content
creation is like I just work on it until
I like it and then whether or not other
people like it is just it's a moot point
I don't I don't even think about it
because it's it's not even a concern of
mine because why would it be right
and and I know that's so easy for me to
say but I've talked to many other
YouTubers about this and they they don't
seem to have the same mindset for it and
I I kind of like get it like I
understand conceptually the idea of
wanting to have everything that you do
liked by other people or be liked by
other people but it's like God I work so
hard on just me liking myself like isn't
that isn't that enough of a battle like
why do I gotta why do I gotta fight
other people's battles to like me for
them and that's not my job that's their
job like that I don't have time for
that you know what I mean I just don't
have time for that yeah I got enough to
do for myself yeah
will I retire from YouTube I've not I'll
probably go down with this ship Kicking
and Screaming I don't know YouTube will
die someday and then I'll move on to
something else but at the same time I
like it here it's fun
it's fun until it's not fun I'm not
really going to worry about doing
something else yeah if I find something
that's more fun and I need to dedicate
all my time to it sure yeah absolutely
but this is fun I like it yeah
what's my favorite part of filming the
movie so far uh
hey
I don't really know probably the sound
design that was very fun we were over in
uh Austin talking sound and that was
just like on a conceptual level just
very very cool I love sound and
obviously this movie needs a lot of good
sound
um and so we just so happened to have
like the best person for the job in
terms of sound which is great because
you know I've been working with Brad for
a little bit now and um he's just very
talented so he's I told him you know
it's such a tragedy in within space and
heist with markiplier
um I kept telling him like I'm so sorry
man you're so talented but the majority
of people who watch Heist and space are
gonna watch it on their phone and you
should have seen the color just drain
from his face you know this guy that's
worked on you know most of Robert
Rodriguez's movies you know he's worked
on tons of pro projects He just won an
Emmy you know and he's just like no okay
I said yeah man I'm sorry look as much
as I can tell you guys that you should
watch you know space and Heist on a good
TV with a nice sound system you're not
gonna do it I know the statistics I know
the statistics and the statistics would
blow your mind that would blow your mind
you know how you know the percentage of
people that watched it on a mobile
device this might have been an iPad but
even so it's not good enough do you want
to know the number because I know the
number I know the number and it's
depressing you wanna know the number
84 percent
84 of you 84 of you watched space on a
mobile device
I couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
it I could not believe it I was just I
was just
oh she's like
oh no we work so hard I don't know if
they consider a laptop a mobile device I
don't think so I think there's a
separate category for laptop maybe there
is I can't remember I haven't looked in
a while but it's like it's like PC and
desktop and then TV and mobile maybe
they do count laptops maybe it's it's
not as bad on a laptop I guess because
that's slightly bigger than a phone but
the speaker's usually on a laptop aren't
the greatest even if you have like a
Macbook it's not that great
um they say as much as you know Apple
will say who's recording studio quality
speakers it's like it's a laptop it's
not going to be that great so maybe
maybe they Chromebooks are counted as
mobile oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah laughter I I would I
would accept a laptop because I get
that's like you know that's what most
people have TVs most people have a TV
come on okay it's harder to make the
choices out of theory but come on you
know that
anyway whatever
it's fine
iPad whatever I'm over it because this
one is going to be in theaters so you
have no excuse it's going to be in
theaters it's going to be in Dolby Atmos
you're gonna have the best sound
experience of your goddamn life and
you're gonna watch it in theaters and
not on your phone
gonna make you do it I'm gonna make you
do it look this guy's too talented for
you to watch this on your phone
too talented
God damn yeah so you get ready you get
ready if you haven't experienced at most
before well I don't know most people
have at this point because I mean most
of you have seen a movie probably
recently yeah
well you couldn't wait until it's out of
theaters God you know Screw you he'll
screw you you're gonna watch it on your
phone just to spite me no not IMAX oh my
God not IMAX
do you know how hard it is to film IMAX
you probably don't but like you know you
know what it takes to make an IMAX movie
an actual one not just like played in an
IMAX because it probably would be played
in an IMAX capable theater that's
different than actual IMAX I'm axis
IMAX is impossible like there's no way
you just casually do an IMAX project
right you you don't like you just don't
number one the camera itself is massive
The Reel of film is ungodly it's just
it's way too much trouble Oppenheimer
was an IMAX and that was like the first
IMAX movie real IMAX movie in like seven
years or something like that and there's
a reason because oh man
iMac are you talking no I'm not iMac
like a Macintosh computer IMAX
I not iMac
are you sweet slower child
I just saw a comment someone was like
iMac is bad I hate iMac I'm like
no it's
no I'm uh
or bad
that's so adorable that's really that's
really adorable yeah that's good yeah
um I'm hoping I'm hoping UK I'm hoping
um but I can't I can't say for certain
because International is just like a
whole different Beast it's a whole
different Beast I I have no idea give me
give me a few months and I'll have a
better answer for you but I don't really
know yeah
anyway yeah where the gaming I've been
posting videos I've been back on the
videos you go video You Go video you go
see my video I've been I'm back I'm back
baby baby I'm back I'm on a roll I'm
back baby
I'm back baby
go check out the videos that I've been
making I get cool stuff coming on the
way
yeah what happened to Ethan dead to me
do you care for numbers on my videos no
I haven't cared about numbers in a long
time
yeah um I stopped caring about numbers
uh probably about
maybe like 2017 or something like that
and I talked about this a lot so I've
talked about this before of just like
the idea that you know my goal for the
longest time was to be a big YouTuber
that was my only real goal and then when
you hit that goal you kind of just get
there and you're like
okay
now what you know what I mean like that
that's kind of what happens is just just
um
you just I don't know it's not a real
good goal or something to focus on
anyway so no I I and I'm not saying like
for anyone that cares about numbers
sucks and is dumb and I'm smart that's
like not what it's about not caring
about something just means like not
thinking about it it's not hating
something that's caring about something
in a negative way you know what I mean
there's a difference it's just uh you
gotta you gotta remove yourself from
that because it gets in the way of
everything you know and I know what
you're thinking easy for me to say I
already am I'm I'm doing whatever uh but
at the same time I think me stepping
back from that rat race and like caring
about so much is the reason why I'm
still here you know what I mean because
think about it I've been doing I've been
doing YouTube for like
11 years now
11 years
um and I'm still here
making stuff you know and and it's not
like oh yeah you stop caring about
numbers You're Gonna Last Forever that's
not it either what I shifted my
attention was caring about what I was
making you know what I mean I cared
about you know enjoying the process
whether it was a like a complicated
video or a higher production thing or a
stupid video you know caring about all
of it just like having attention to
detail in those elements of it even on
the dumb you know and having fun
the entire time that that and
challenging myself you know more than
just having fun because you could just
because at the same time I don't want to
give the illusion that like if you have
fun you're gonna find success because
that's not it either like I I find
success because I challenged myself and
I exceed my previous limitations right I
I I level up in terms of my creative
potential because I always am chasing
new things that I've never done before
and I want to do those things because
it's an opportunity for me to learn both
about myself in a new part of the craft
of just making things in general and by
applying myself to the craft of making
things and removing myself from the the
pursuit of Reckless numbers which if you
want to do that that's fine I'm not
saying it's necessarily a bad thing I
think it's just like it's a road that
has no end right and that's fine if you
want to do that I'm also on a road that
doesn't end because self-improvement and
learning it has diminishing returns and
also you as a person kind of diminish As
Time Marches On it's called getting
older and you you start to uh
you start to lose the ability to exceed
yourself but in in a weird way you kind
of learn to exceed Yourself by honing
and focusing what you can do and so I'm
not there yet but you know we'll all be
there someday so it's it's really just
like I I say that I don't care about
numbers with confidence because I just
don't think about them you know what I
mean I just don't think about them
there's there's Parts where it is of
course important to be able to like you
know continue to make bigger and better
things but it's not always about making
bigger and better things sometimes it's
making it's about making smaller and
better things sometimes you know you can
spread yourself so wide and reach for
such a brilliant height that you've
spread yourself completely thin because
no matter what at the end of the day
you're just going to be one person you
can never be more than one person you
can never be more than just yourself so
by remembering that you can focus on
just improving what you as one
individual can apply yourself to and
having that Focus increases the amount
of a difference that you can make
because it's just like pressure over
area you know it's it's you you apply
yourself in a very focused manner it
doesn't mean that you don't try just as
hard because I work unbelievably hard
and I I want to work hard and I want to
exceed myself and I want to challenge
myself and to challenge myself it takes
more and more effort I don't lack an
effort by forgetting about numbers I
actually apply more effort now than I
ever have in my life
um and that's because I enjoy the
process
of that effort the application of the
effort is what drives me and the seeing
of what I can do is what drives me you
know I'm I'm thrilled that there's a
whole new world of creative potential
that I can get into with with filmmaking
and stuff like this it may also be
something that I lose interest in in a
year you know I may I may be done with
this one and never do another one again
that might be what it is I don't think
so because I've already got more ideas
of what to do but you know every once in
a while you run into a you run into a
dead end somewhere and it's like it's
not really a dead end it's just you got
to make a left turn or a right turn
somewhere you know and as long as you if
if you just like keep staring at a brick
wall and you're trying to think oh how
do I get around this brick wall or how
do I go through this brick wall you're
never going to make it through the wall
sometimes you gotta backtrack sometimes
you gotta make a turn yeah you gotta do
something else you gotta try something
else if you don't try anything else
you're never going to know your own
limitations because you will get good at
the one thing you're bashing your head
against and you'll you'll get good at
bashing your head against the wall you
know I mean yeah so uh
that's about it
um any advice for starting a channel I
have no idea I don't know whatever uh
good luck uh have fun maybe I don't know
I I I couldn't put it into words right
away
um but I I also think like you know
starting a channel is uh an exercise in
problem solving you know what I mean
it's it's a challenge right it's a
challenge so if you're you're when
you're starting a channel what's your
objective grow okay that's a puzzle how
do you solve it I can't answer that for
you because I don't know what you're
capable of making and I'm willing to bet
that you don't know what you're capable
of making right so already you know that
you need to just illuminate the path
forward before you can even walk on it
you need to see what the path even is
before you can start and sometimes
seeing what the path is taking that
first step and then falling
precipitously to your doom
um but yeah it's a puzzle it's a puzzle
I can't answer for you only you can
answer from into that I can't I can't do
that for you yeah
advice on editing I am a god at editing
I am
my advice is give up you'll never be as
good as me you'll never beat me and I'm
so good I don't know if I say editing uh
it's a skill
you just got to keep doing it you know
yeah keep doing it
you'll get better
that's how it is for everything you know
that is literally how it is for
everything but you don't do it
mindlessly right you think about it you
know you try to you you think very
critically about it and and you do it
more that's that's that's there yeah
lyxian edits everything for me I don't
do anything
ah
I don't I don't discredit luxian's
editing at all but if you asked if you
ask elixian uh if he does everything
that is not true at all and it's a
discredit also to the other editors who
work Marcus and Rachel on many of the
videos that you enjoy
um so it's not just lexian out there and
also he's very very good he's extremely
good I don't give me hey don't get me
wrong at all but he he is one guy and he
cannot do it all like he cannot do it
all and I wouldn't want him to do it all
like people need breaks every once in a
while everyone you know everyone in the
in the FNAF ruin was like look she's so
great for editing in uh Mark screaming
in the background that was me
clever uh looks
Elixir editing
this movie well all of us are helping
but me that's right better than you ever
thought you didn't even know you didn't
even know
fools no I mean it's no big deal at all
if you think that lexian does everything
that's also fine I don't mind but their
Marcus and Rachel do do a lot of work in
there incredibly talented too and they
help out to uh an amazing degree
especially with you know keeping things
up to date on everything yeah
do I edit the final product that uh my
editors give me uh not for most things
usually like seeing gives the final
stamp of approval on stuff and you know
he'll put in like the the elixion edits
and whatnot um but for things like that
are bigger projects like the movie I
have to at some point it just goes off
to me it just goes to me and I have to
finish it that's that's just long and
short of it
um because it's just like no one else
can it's at the point it's just a
creative Endeavor and oh at that point
you know everyone has different creative
inputs and I wrote the thing so I'm
gonna edit the thing you know
advice for not thinking so critically uh
turn your brain off don't think just
don't think I don't know that's a such a
conversation yeah
that's uh that's a long conversation
can't even think about having that yeah
um
Ethan suggested doing this honest too
and Mark kill them to avoid spending
another year together
true how did you know about that how'd
you know about that no thoughts head
empty absolutely yeah
advice for playing Five Nights at
Freddy's 3.
I don't even remember I don't even
remember how you gotta use the noise to
keep uh keep spring trap controlled and
then you
like something about keeping them in a
certain spot so that it limited the
amount of vents that he could access
other than being mindful of like when he
was going for another event because
there was a certain there was a certain
clue that when he wasn't in a certain
place or a couple certain places that he
was definitely going for something else
because sometimes he would be line it
back for the last camera and go in that
vent and that was tricky because he was
for some reason very fast when he did
that so he had to quickly shift your uh
trap over to the other side but it was
like
I don't remember I don't remember at all
it was very annoying it was extremely
annoying yeah
yep
um
advice for playing in these are the
darks and man I've never gotten advice
on how to play I'll give you advice on
frostpunk you know what you know what's
funny about frostpunk not many people
know that I was super into that game I
did a stream on it and you know I guess
that video did pretty well but
um
it's uh
I think of that when I was trying to do
it on the hardest difficulty but you
guys had to make choices to get
different laws for me and also even
wasting a few seconds just like talking
to you guys cost me that entire run
um but I love frostbunk and I can give a
lot of advice on how to play frostbunk
yeah
frostbunk's so good God damn I love
frostpunk that music
The Vibes everything's so cohesive oh
the depressing atmospheres go great
will I always be the king of five nights
and Freddy's yeah
sorry everybody else
always will be till the day I die
you can try to take Crown from me but I
don't think it'll work
anyway probably yeah
um
I'd watch frostpunk stream again I'd
have to I'd have to get back into
frostpunk I kind of played out of it I
played every scenario on the max
difficulty with no deaths it was tough
but I loved it every minute of it I
loved every minute of it yeah
how do you rate your taste in video
games poor
probably very poor you know very poor
yeah
advice on script writing
um right
that's that's about it that's all I
really got uh don't spend too much time
brainstorming spend as much time as
possible actually typing out words
um you can trick yourself very easily
into thinking that brainstorming is
effective and going to help you get
through that thing you'd be surprised at
how little it helps um and you'd be
surprised how much more helpful it is
just to type random nonsense words even
if they don't make any goddamn sense
just type words that sounds like the
craziest advice or the most simple
advice or something like that if you're
trying to write and you're stuck on
something write gobbledygook literally
right gobbledygook and then if you're
like okay Jack and Jill where are they
gonna go ah man should they go up a hill
ah should they go up a mountain oh frick
Jack and Jill they went uh got some milk
from the store the store rhymes with
boar they got a spear to kill the boar
the boar was on they had a duel on a
hill no Jack and Joe they went up in a
Hell to have a duel with a bar you know
you just write just write anything it'll
get you there your brain will connect
the dots and you then before you know it
you have your first shitty draft and you
got your first shitty draft boom great
write it over again just do it again
just literally also don't be afraid to
let go don't be afraid to delete do
not be afraid don't hold on to
everything so tightly don't think you
have gold don't ever think you have gold
don't think that what you've written
down is the most sacred thing you've
ever seen if if you write something down
understand you could delete it at any
given moment and that'd be fine because
then you would rewrite it and in
rewriting it you would make more
connections and you would go further and
further nothing you write is gold
nothing you write is sacred in fact get
in the habit of sometimes just going I
delete it all
whatever I'm going to rewrite that all
because I hate it because you'll spend
more time rereading your own words
instead of writing
than you ever would actually just
writing so just write even if you have
to delete everything you did because
it's not sacred and it's not the final
product anyway and you're gonna have to
rewrite it anyway because it's the first
shitty draft no matter what you think
it's genius it's not
throw it away it's not worth it just do
it over again uh if you hold on to it
too tightly you'll lose sight of
absolutely all the other ideas that are
floating out there yeah
what's the movie rated uh well it hasn't
been officially rated yet but um it's
not gonna be for kids I can tell you
that I can tell you that I can tell you
yeah
if you want to write you got to read a
lot too that also is true yeah you
should read a lot and you should read a
lot from a lot of sources I'm a bad
example of this because I pretty much
exclusively read Warhammer 40K books but
at least they have many authors and many
types of books
um so as long as you're reading I think
that's really what matters yeah read a
lot if you want to write you're gonna
have to read eventually just don't get
too caught up in reading your own stuff
because that stuff doesn't matter yeah
anyway
um yeah Warhammer I didn't do way too
much for him before the gay books
what is the title my self-explanatory
Ethan's dead to me
how do I deal with demotivation oh I
mean I I get it as much as anybody else
I suppose
um you'd be shocked at how motivating
though a gun to the head is uh you'd be
shocked at how motivating a looming
deadline uh that everything is counting
on is so uh
terrible advice but if you constantly
get yourself in situations where you
have to do it or everything else will
crumble around you uh you'd be surprised
at what you can get done
good that's my advice don't listen to it
don't don't do it don't do it deadline
pressure yeah
let's see
um hey Mark ADHD question here do you
have any advice as to how to stay
focused with ADHD my parents won't let
me get ADHD meds so focusing can be
really hard
um yeah that that can be tough I don't
know obviously how old you are and don't
say in chat like it's fine uh but it's
it can be difficult I outlined this a
little bit before I I would wonder why
your parents are opposed to ADHD
medication I get it it's they teach
their own
um but there are better medications out
there like there there really are and I
think like it's it's kind of a different
landscape than it once was
um like the the medication that I'm I'm
on is
um
forget about the chemical composition of
it but it's on the methylphenidate side
of of medications there's like the
amphetamine side there's non-simulants
and there's methylphenidate
um there's a whole bunch of different
types of of medication for it so I don't
know if they're just thinking about one
like usually when people think of ADHD
medication they think of like Adderall
and Adderall is actually a very old drug
um and it's you know there's a lot of
research out there that Adderall it's
not the best for you especially for long
term so I understand that
um but the one I take a stars is over on
the methylphenidate side and um it's
it's just like there there are different
effects for different people and this is
something that can only be diagnosed by
a doctor but even getting to the
informing stage is is sometimes
important if they're worried about like
a stimulant medication they're a
non-stimulant medications as well
um so it's uh it is it is different for
everybody and there is not just one
thing unfortunately there are doctors
out there that are just like ADHD
there's your Adderall you know like
that's how they that's and it's not
really how it should be it should be a
long conversation and a a thing called
titration which is the typical way that
it does which titration if you took
science classes is like slowly ramping
up the dose you know slow addition you
start at an extremely low dose because
for some people they might need a higher
dose for some people a low dose is
sometimes too much so it's like teach
teach their own and it's something that
like it's a it should be an actual
conversation with a doctor
um and uh that's something where if your
parents are
completely opposed to any kind of
medication I would just think that
they're only thinking about one when
there's really many so yeah
um am I happy right now I am I'm doing
pretty good I vented about Ethan is the
movie going to be in theaters yes yes
and you're gonna watch it on a in a
theater with a good sound system it's
going to be mixed in Atmos
I go witches you're gonna watch it good
don't really understand what ADHD is is
it an ability to focus or more
complicated it's more complicated it's
um what it boils down to I think and I'm
not a scientist I think it boils down to
like a dopamine deficiency stuff like
that so most of the medications out
there try to either
allow you to have more of a dopamine
Supply or maintain your ability to
maintain your or it affects your ability
to maintain your dopamine Supply so
that's usually how it goes it's it's I
think it is pretty much a dopamine
deficiency but I can't really explain it
in scientific terms because I'm not a
doctor yeah
um why did you choose to make a movie
based on iron alone seemed like a good
idea fun so far yeah absolutely who is
producing the movie me
yeah
will it be available internationally I
don't know we need an Ethan apology
video with tears I wouldn't accept it
even if it did I wouldn't accept it even
if it was a possibility no
no or can we do game suggestions
absolutely
absolutely maybe I should become a
doctor good god no
God no yeah absolutely not no thank you
yeah
why am I mad at Ethan why wouldn't I be
why wouldn't I be
this is just a Super Chat that's like
I'm on ADT meds
it's good that's good that's good I'm
not criticized I'm just looking
it's a fun thing to shout at the top of
your lungs you go into a crowded room
I'm on 90 minutes
all right okay cool did I click bait at
you uh no I explained this earlier he
stole a game from me before I was able
to play it that I told him about so it's
basically sacrilege in the YouTube world
you know so he's dead to me
yep Ethan is the enemy hip who uh who's
starring
wide release or limited uh wide-ish
let's go wide-ish
I don't know what wide or limited means
but wide-ish
what program am I using to edit the
movie I'm so glad you asked
I have officially switched over from
Premiere
to DaVinci Resolve honestly if you're
still editing anything in premiere
I feel so sorry for you I struggled with
that for years I I started out with
Premiere back when it was reliable
fast efficient streamlined it was good
I saw every update of Premiere reduce
functionality slow it down more crashes
worse performance features you don't
need they would change up how it works
for no reason
I swear to God move into DaVinci Resolve
was the best thing I ever did it would
change your life anything other than
Premiere will probably change your
existence DaVinci Resolve there is no
reason you should be on Premiere because
number one getting DaVinci Resolve is a
one-time payment
it's not a subscription
it's not I like I can't even explain how
important that is on a fundamental level
it is one time purchase you have it with
all the updates it is amazing and you
could probably find it because they they
give a license away with all their
camera equipment there's probably people
that you know that have a license just
sitting unused you could probably get it
from them yeah it's oh man it's great
yeah so DaVinci Resolve is fantastic
they even have a free version they have
a free version to try out the paid
version is for the studio so if you
don't even need the studio uh features
the free version might just be good
enough for you forever who knows if all
you're doing is editing the YouTube
videos that may be all you need yeah
absolutely oh
oh
anyway yeah
so yeah yeah so I I'm phasing out all
Prim Adobe based stuff because Adobe
just like they got
uh they got real complacent and then
they got real slow and they haven't been
able to fix their and what's
hilarious is I look on Tick Tock and
I'll see these really dumb ads for Adobe
on Tick Tock like trying to appeal you
should edit your videos in Premiere look
how you can change the picture color to
Blue you like blue rightly this is the
stupidest thing I've ever seen in my
life how about you make your software
actually work that would be great how
about you make it not crash how about
you make it be able to actually play
back an h.264 file without stuttering
you know something that I was able to do
with it I don't know eight years ago and
it worked just fine on eight years ago
Hardware but for some reason now today
my 240 90s can't even play it oh because
you don't even have dual GPU support for
Premiere that's really weird isn't it
huh that's a little strange don't you
think
so dumb
so dumb anyway yeah DaVinci is superior
it just is there's no question about it
absolutely there's some features that I
wish it had but they do improve every
version so it's like I can't even can't
even compare yep
anyway
yeah all right I I gotta wrap it up here
I gotta I gotta do I gotta wrap it up
here
yeah I run multi-gpu some people thought
I got 240 90s for gaming and I'm like
that is not why I got
a computer with two 40 90s that's not
why I do so much more than that
yeah
anyway
um I gotta get out of here I gotta get
out of here
um I am going to uh get back to work
I've got a lot of stuff to do it's gonna
be a pretty tough two weeks and then I'm
going to Korea for chuseok and then um I
will be back but I have videos I'm gonna
keep up with recordings if you haven't
been keeping up with distractible please
do uh there's tons of new stuff if you
haven't been keeping up with go my
favorite sports team those have been
awesome episodes go check those out uh
links are in the description for those
we do episodes of distractible twice a
week we do go once a week that's three
videos we do video now of me talking
with Bob Wade and Tyler three times a
week if you want that kind of content
with me talking with my friends
distractible and go are for you if you
haven't tried it yet go check it out and
if you haven't checked out in a while
definitely do there's a lot of fun stuff
that we've been doing on distractible
kind of in the middle of my dictorial
phase on distractible
um but seriously distractible it's fun
times uh people in chat if you if you're
a listener to distractible
um typing chat what your favorite recent
episode was or it could be an old one it
just can't be Bob's fridge boss fridge
is at this point sold we've had so much
gold since there even the Burl's bonus
episode is gold uh so if you guys uh
give your favorite ones in chat so other
people can have suggestions go to
Spotify you can watch the video only on
Spotify for both go and distractible and
it's just a ton of stuff getting older
which one which one which one bread that
was a good one that was a weirdly enough
bread was a very funny one red was a
great one riddles and rhyme that was
that was a good one yeah that's a great
one Bob's and the bees the burls yeah it
was good yeah Mac versus Windows got me
so much hate
as if and I know I've been saying I'm
gonna leave for a while forever now but
I okay so I recently discovered this is
actually a discover uh of mine because
I've been I've been um I've been PC for
so long right I've done PC most of my
life and I've always been a PC guy but
recently with apple silicon
is suddenly those computers are so much
better for video editing period it's not
even close better for video editing
then my PC is and it's not that my PC is
less powerful than the Mac people were
like getting all my about it no
that Mac is more efficient
at doing it I can edit the entire movie
with raw footage on my laptop not
plugged in
I could be on a 12 hour flight to Korea
and be editing the movie with 8K raw
footage on battery and be fine no lag
that's a game changer and anybody that
loves technology you gotta like you
gotta understand this is specifically
for video editing it's not better for
gaming of course it's not it's not
better for 3D modeling of course it's
not
but what it is better for is the
applications you need it to work for and
that's where I like it that's where I
like it
anyway that's all I'll say about that
but yeah that episode was quite divisive
quite divisive quite divisive yeah
absolutely very divisive weird part one
two and three yeah
um
hi I've I've been lingering too long but
thank you so much for joining me on this
uh Adventure it was good catching up to
you with you guys it was good just being
able to chat again
um videos are going to be coming uh
tomorrow they'll be fun stuff I wonder
if that video that I'm thinking of is
done
Hannah yet Maybe by tomorrow
I can't believe oh no that one game
that's gonna be a dumb one it's gonna be
a very dumb one but there it is all
right but thank you uh check out
distractible check out go uh links are
in the description uh you've got a lot
of recommendations for fun episodes to
watch in the chat here and uh yeah thank
you so much for sticking around and I
will get you cool content and fun
updates before you know it lots of fun
stuff on the way so look forward to that
and uh as always I will see you
in the next video
bye guys
bye
goodbye